made entirely of wood without a single  nail the sanctuary of truth in Pattaya  Thailand is a modern-day marvel built  using ancient carving techniques this  religious shrine has been under  construction since 1981 and it isn't  scheduled to be completed any time soon  it was commissioned by a Thai  millionaire who spent his fortune on  projects like this he wanted to keep  ancient wood building techniques alive  the building towers 375 feet and looks  out over the cursed it's for wings are  dedicated to Thai Cambodian Chinese and  Indian iconography a team of 250 wood  carvers have created ornate images of  religious and philosophical significance  throughout the structure the sanctuary  of truth is considered an art  installation religious shrine and  cultural monument all in one although  the creator has passed away and weren't  have an opportunity to see his celestial  masterpiece completed the work continues  according to his specific plans